welcome back to new rock stars the
falcon in the winter soldier series is
carrying on the legacy of captain
america but
where is old man cap and join retirement
or
shall we say dead oh god i hope he's not
that'd be
awful i'm done with death in the mcu you
heard it here first
jessica clemens hosting this rogue
theory the show where we speculate
wildly
about the stuff that you me all of us
are obsessed with
and i have so many wonderful guests
starting with
the maestro of missable detail himself
eric voss hi i'm excited to talk about
uh the
biggest human plot hole that exists in
the mcu
let's do this hey i love the enthusiasm
secondly we have oh my bearded baby boy
my baby boy my baby bad boy tommy
bechtel yes
jessica my moon and stars oh
reunited once again let us forget these
two other fools here
you and i hey i would i would love that
but i have to introduce our third guest
because
he's better than all of us oh i don't
know about that no no no don't return
against tom michelson how are you doing
hey how's it going guys thanks for
having me back fam
i feel like this is better better than
any hex i could have made
any reality and that means tommy's
mephisto i'm calling it now tommy's
mephisto
mark my words mark my words ooh are we
getting
we're getting back into we're talking
about wand division because that's a lot
of hair
i'm just saying right now for everybody
yes it's agatha inspired
it's it's kinky it's curly it's sexy
this show is not about this but i need
to bring everyone's attention to this
wig
because i love it and i'm eating it up
but ultimately rogue theory i know that
we love to say that this isn't like you
know a competitive game
you guys shouldn't be fighting for
points i disagree
this means a lot and if you really want
me to like you you better win
this theory so what we are all
asking what we're all wondering where is
old man cat so
everything we've seen from falcon in the
winter soldier series so far has shown
us that the shield is going to be a main
component it's there the shield that old
cap gave sam at the end of avengers end
game
but no sighting of the old man cap
himself we're not expecting to see a
chris evans cameo in the series but
old cap's whereabouts and status could
be very important to sam and bucky's
mission
and so broader the mcu going forward so
what happened to the old man cap
and what does his status tell us about
the falcon in the winter soldier series
going forward because it's
obviously going to play a main component
the every trailer is just like
he means a lot his his shield is a
symbol so where is he
where is the old guy well as far as like
what the public of the mcu seems to know
uh it seems like they believe captain
america in their eyes is dead like
remember there was that tribute video
that played the beginning spider-man
apart from home
and they're like cap's dead too and then
we're all watching we're like no he's
not he's still alive he's just an old
man but maybe that old man
you know took a wrong step and then
don't say that
i'm working my way up to it though but i
think
either that that could just be the story
that the avengers put out there right
because that moment with bucky and sam
seemed like a private moment i mean hulk
was just around the other side of the
tree
and he didn't look over to be like hey
good
because you know if he hugged that old
man too hard his hundred-year-old bones
would break i don't care how much super
soldier serums in you that's true
banner gives bad hugs bad hugs
but like it seems like they put out some
kind of cover story that captain america
died in the final battle or just he
vanished in the time heist and he gave
his life to save us
and just don't worry about it but i
think
uh if the falcon winter soldier does
address this it's gonna have to be like
a
elderly peggy carter thing in winter
soldier slash civil war
i think he's gonna have to kind of die
off uh
in order to just kind of clip off that
uh that logical loose end
um like it doesn't have to be tasteless
it could just be like he dies peacefully
in his sleep after living a life well
lived and it's fine
and and that's that's all we know
because if he is still alive
you know either the dude is cleaning up
with the ladies in his retirement
village or he's pulling some clint
eastwood el torino [ __ ] and he
is making some enemies in his brooklyn
neighborhood
you don't want someone that holds alive
just like
it's like i get that i get that
i get that and i feel that i guess he
wouldn't have to i know this is not my
show or like this is not when i need to
put my theory in there
but i guess he doesn't necessarily have
to be like dead dead
he could be faking his death dead you
know what i'm talking about
like that dead yeah do you but you want
him to actually
like we want that sadness that
emotionalness of like he is gone
yeah i think he needs to fade away it
could even be like old man biff
and back to future part two who likes
supposed to kind of fade away
he coughs and goes behind a bush and
he's gone stop um
but like the the reason why is we know
chris evans is in talks for two more
marvel films and it's gonna be
too complicated if we have an elderly
version of him alive well it won't be
too complicated for us because we're
nerds but for general audiences
wait which which chris sevens do i
follow and is chris evans gonna get in
that old man makeup every time
oh contraire eric voss i disagree
i disagree and i would like to and i
interject
and i move to strike because i believe
that captain america has moved on to a
better place
and that better place is not heaven my
friends
it's saint petersburg florida where old
people go to
thrive and here's what i think
what we're going to get in the falcon
winter soldier is what i call the old
crisscross
crisscross and for this case the chris
stands for chris evans
yes captain america is dead long
live captain america his death has been
faked fabricated an illusion
something to keep the people calm move
forward but where is captain america
he's in his mansion in saint petersburg
good investments
eastman kodak in the 60s xerox in the
70s
have made him a millionaire nay a
billionaire and now
much like bruce wayne in the batman
beyond cartoon he's calling all the
shots with sam and bucky
from his control room with his large
leather recliner
old man cap the puppet master and that's
what we'll find out in the final episode
they've been getting help from a
mysterious source all along and that
help
is none other than captain america okay
those are really good
theories the only problem is that
they're wrong like
i mean unfortunately hey jessica said
just like it said to come out swinging
like i'm excited i think i'm actually
gonna like thread the
thread the line between both of those so
yeah i think they're going to establish
that he's dead like
it'll just make it easier for the world
to not you know even know he exists for
his own sake to not have to
you know it's not gonna be like
paparazzi outside of his house all the
time
but he's gonna he's gonna be effectively
dead to everybody but i think
to a select few they'll know he's alive
because you know they're they're gonna
have to bring him back for sure and i
don't think they're gonna want the
audience to
feel or to know that he's really dead
and evans has you know like
in addition to kind of what eric was
saying i mean he's he's kind of alluded
to never say never
right and marvel just cannot pass up the
perfect opportunity to put him in so
i i was thinking if anything the weird
thing i couldn't help but notice in
wanda vision was that they had to make a
kind of a scroll reference
you know with that monica scene at the
end and now we've had two properties in
a row we're talking about squirrels
right we've had
far from home and we've had this and so
maybe they're setting their chess pieces
in place for
cap to you know come back as young chris
evans but maybe he'll be a squirrel or
something like that
where they're oh they don't want to put
the nail in the coffin and say that he's
dead for the audience
um but they are definitely leaving the
door like cracked open a little bit so
that he can come back and
be in the show in some other way and if
it's not that then he's probably just
at the gym getting old man buff like jk
simmons something like that
one of those what are those two okay
okay i see that i got it from
yours i kind of get it with voss
a little bit with tommy but like dude so
the public
knows about old man cap in your guys's
theories no
i don't know you don't think you are too
no
you said the door was open a little bit
and then boss you said
that he's gonna die okay okay wait okay
private private funeral private funeral
i think only the avengers kept that
secret because it's just too complicated
and because the writers didn't really
have an answer but because it would be
too complicated
to explain the public just know that gap
is gone now
and he gave his life to help these
stones get back to where they need to go
so he just like vanished during the time
heist and people don't really question
it's just like
the version of captain america who they
knew doesn't exist in the world anymore
so they just assumed death
oh when i talk about it when i talk
about the door open i meant for the
audience but yeah the world i think i
agree with eric
the world effectively believes he's gone
and died in
one way so there is a tombstone there's
all of that but i don't think he
as far as you know we and maybe even sam
and then but like we know he's not
really dead
yeah and i don't think uh cap is because
it's the
comics it's a world of comics no one
ever stays dead like
gomorrah came back you know and they
just pull them from alternating
yeah it's a different time and that's it
same with vision he's being
manifested via magic within a hex
reality they're gonna do the same
or not the same thing but a similar kind
of thing with chris evans i think
but the answer that we'll get in a
falcon winter soldier i think will only
be
embedded in the shield itself because i
think the shield kind of represents
it's like a symbol for captain america
in all kinds of ways
yeah but the soul of steve rogers is
going to live on in that shield
and that's why sam wilson feels like
this doesn't belong to me
it's essentially and it feels so wrong
in the hands of someone like john walker
so i think at some point my i mean if
i'm gonna go rogue here
i'm gonna say that shield is made of
proto-adamantium and then scientists are
gonna be like this does not exist in the
world
and then someone will be like well not
our world and then
that's how we're going to get in
existence of an alternate reality where
the weapons plus program was continued
uh to uh develop more and more of this
kind of adamantium
um or from vibranium that was uh used
for the shield
into more weaponized uh things that
created wolverine right
from weapons plus to weapons x and i
think
in one of these chris evans stories is
gonna just take place in an else world
but marvel doesn't have the answers yet
on what that multiverse will look like
we'll just know that shield
does not belong from this world from
this reality
so you're saying wait the shield that he
gave yeah to sam
and it does not yeah i'm getting that
from the russo brothers who said that
that captain america that old man came
from an alternate reality
so i'm taking their answers i'm not
saying this [ __ ] he lived his life
you look the shield it's a different
design it's got that black kind of line
through the silver part
that is true it's got notches
wait okay so okay so you think hold up a
damn minute hold up wait a minute let me
get some shield up in this so you're
saying the shield
so the old man cap yeah he is from an
alternate timeline so he brought that
shield back that shield made something
different and then the when they return
that shield to the museum
that's when they're going to take it and
realize that it's made of something
different and they're going to
take it apart to make something more
hazardous a weapon out of that
i mean that'd be cool i i didn't yeah
that's that's totally your theory i love
that idea what i'm thinking is that it's
this shield's gonna bounce around to a
lot of people's different possessions
it's gonna be like the football of the
series
uh and it's gonna be like the infinity
gauntlet of the series like who's got
possession of this now but it's gonna
unfold over six episodes
i believe and so you're gonna it's gonna
be in the museum at some point we know
it'll be in john walker stands we know
that from the trailer
we uh we know that steve and bucky have
their hands on it allegedly
allegedly that shield i think it is that
shield
i think yeah but i i only saw it from
behind in that one football shot shot
but yeah i think it's going to bounce
around and at some point maybe that's
why they go to madrid
is they they're like this shield's kind
of weird and someone inspects it and
they're like
you know this isn't vibranium this isn't
just pure vibranium
it's a different alloy and they're like
this yeah
i love that it's kind of similar to a
theory that i had eric that i was
thinking about where
yeah the i either that is the one shield
being passed around
or you know sam will have the real one
and this john walker will have this
other us-made one
and then when it comes to a head i
already imagine a scene of like
sam shields shattering the other one and
then them discovering that this is an
adamantium
an situation cap shield this is their
chance like this is totally their chance
and again that's what i was saying x-men
connection i had a similar kind of thing
with the adamantium so when you watch i
was like oh
adamantium yeah and to make it i love
this shield
that's great it rips through the other
one that scene
will probably i will just walk up and
just walk into the forest and die
because it'll be the best scene i've
ever seen in a movie i would love that i
would love to see
sam wilson throw that shield and it rips
through like the us agent shield
oh god shout out so do you guys think
like i have so many questions
we have like a list of questions but i
also have personally i have questions
and these two intersect do you think
it's gonna be over the span of the six
episodes or we're gonna get that at the
beginning like it's gonna be a quick
like buy and then they're gonna start it
or is it gonna
go spread out throughout the six
episodes i think that it's going to be
kind of teased and then we'll have a
definite answer episode six
i agree i think if you were to lead this
series call the falcon winter soldier
with
old cap's funeral scene it would be too
much of a gut punch to open this show
really i think so it would just be like
cap is dead
move on this would be it'd be like
leading captain america
uh the civil war with peggy carter's
funeral scene no we had
you have different action you get the
audience on board and then you pull
uh their heartstrings later on i feel
like that would be something for episode
six rather than episode one if we did
see his funeral
i was thinking that like based off based
off of like one division one division i
think has taught
me personally even a lot about marvel's
approach to this show and i almost feel
like
that you know they might even just
allude to it or mention it but never
fully address it because it's not about
captain america per se it's
the falcon right the winter soldier and
it's about them being friends them
you know sam earning the shield so i
actually feel like there might be a
one-off comment maybe in like the first
or second up or something but then i
don't know if they'll necessarily just
address it because like like how just
like how mephisto didn't yet uh come
into the mcu
you watched yourself you watched
yourself
i'm still i'm still going hard anyway
but one division taught me though that
you know marvel
is likes to you know they're bringing
these characters to this world to tell
their story
without necessarily having this like
deuce ex machina thing coming at the
last minute and change the
change the game so i was well that's why
i was thinking it would be like how i'm
far
from home spider-man how we had that
little tribute to iron man
i understand that he had a full funeral
in the last movie but like
i thought it would i thought we'd enter
like that kind of case of just like
damn he's dead bye i wanted uh
spider-man far from home to just
continue the sprawling reveal of the
people at the funeral so it would just
be like
ned and aunt may and then pull back even
more
and it would be flash and it would be
michael keaton and pull back even more
and then you get to dc pearson as new
master 69 apparently
i'm so excited about that oh dc
you were in an episode with dc sorry you
were hanging out yeah
[Music]
very smart too very smart i'm so happy
to see him in the series i'm glad they
brought him back and was like i'm the
new master 69
you know so many people took that name
on like xbox live
guaranteedly yeah i was so mad i kind of
wanted to take it but i knew it was gone
okay okay you guys okay oh my god
to give you guys points for this is hard
as hell
those theories because the last theory i
hosted they were just so crazy that i
was like i'm going with the craziest one
tommy you know i love you i love you so
much so i'm gonna give you
um two cookies yeah i love you too
they were my snack that i haven't
started to eat yet so i'll touch them
um and then oh
and this one's hard this one's so hard
because tom
i literally we have the same mind i was
thinking the exact same way so i want to
like give you the most points because we
thought the same way
but then i'm like voss i wasn't thinking
that and this is rogue theory
and if i can't use my theory like i have
to use your theory
so okay tom i'm giving you three cookies
three great delicious looking cookies i
i'll take it
and vos you son of a [ __ ]
i'm giving you three and a half a branch
i broke this one because i right
it's a good theory it's a great theory
thank you that tracks that's right i'm
gonna look on my end they come out
as sparkle box
okay okay you can't eat the paper
glitter
you can't eat the water paper i'm not
okay so we're going to speculate more
about more and about [ __ ] in the
winter soldier series but first a few
words from the folks that help us bring
you rogue theory
every week well first we want to thank
our friends at masterclass for
sponsoring this episode
masterclass lets you learn from the
world's best minds anytime anywhere and
at your own pace learn songwriting from
alicia keys or
writing from r.l stein the the
horrifying
writer of my childhood that gave me
nightmares between ages eight through
ten
i'm i'm afraid to put on halloween masks
because of our old stein
with over 100 classes from a range of
world-class instructors
that thing you've always wanted to do is
closer than you think
at new rockstars we have been digging
into the filmmaking master classes they
got classes from helen mirren ron howard
spike lee
you can even take a class from hans
zimmer and finally understand all those
scoring soundtrack easter eggs that i'm
always talking about
masterclass is accessible on your phone
on the web smart tv
each class is broken out into individual
video lessons usually around 10 minutes
long
members can explore at their own pace
and each class is supported by
downloadable materials like lessons
and recipes you can find all available
master classes at masterclass.com
i highly recommend you check it out get
unlimited access to
every master class and as a rogue theory
viewer slash listener you will get 15
off an annual membership go to
masterclass.com
rogue that's masterclass.com rogue for
15 percent off at masterclass
the rockstars is excited to partner with
stereo app on a weekly live shows
download stereo app for free right now
stereo.com
new rockstars i think it's going to be
below or somewhere
is just go to it every week we're
pumping out at least four shows
previewing what's coming up in pop
culture on the channel and reviewing a
big hits from the previous weeks and
most of the content exists only on
stereo that week
and that is exclusive and also you don't
have to pay for stereo that's the best
part you just download the app and come
talk to us
uh the best part also is that you get to
be a part of the show
submit audio messages with your
questions theories and reactions we'll
play your messages and react to them
and if off-screen producer zack is on
the show he'll tell you why you're wrong
feels like that's zach's mo anytime i
talk to him so if he's telling you why
you're wrong
it's just how he is that's just his kind
of bread and butter you can go back and
hear previous episodes of our shows on
the stereo
app which is also great access to live
shows share your questions and theories
and interact with us in the real time by
downloading the free stereo app at
stereo dot com
slash new walk stars it's right here
probably
that stereo dot com slash new rockstars
it's time now turn me loose baby our
friends
blue chew have a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients
as viagra and cialis but in a chewable
form
and at a fraction of the cost that's
right are you trying to get
sprung but swallowing one of those big
itchy pills is just too hard for you
well fluchu is going to let you crush it
up chew it down and
bing bang boom baby it's rocket ships to
mars but in a sexual way
luke 2 is an online prescription service
so
no doctor's office or pharmacy trips it
ships straight to your door
in a discreet package but you know me no
shame in the game i want my bluetooth
delivered by
a college marching band it's big boner
time
all right let's go yes sign up at
bluechew.com you consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you receive your
prescription within days that's days
folks not weeks
within calendar days you're taking a
trip to erection town
population you and hopefully someone
else because if you're taking a blue
chew and doing it by yourself
well you're off on guard but you're also
a bit of a psycho is your licensed
medical
providers work with you to find the
right ingredients and strength and if
you hate swallowing pills good news
blue chew is chewable like i said just
like it says in the name so if you could
benefit from a little extra confidence
and god knows we all can right now
when it's time to perform visit
bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
audience
try bluetooth free when you use our
promo code
rogue at checkout just pay the five
dollar shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code rogue to receive your first
month free
a month subscription we thank bluetooth
for sponsoring this podcast
oh yes and we're back uh captain america
shield is not
only made a badass vibranium weapon but
an important symbol as we all know
so sam had it by the end of endgame but
who's gonna have the shield and the
title of captain america by the end of
falcon and winner's soldier is it gonna
be sam
bucky the us agent uh
a scroll uh any who who who
anybody uh the theory i've pitched
before
with uh on inside marvel recently is
that you know
knowing malcolm spellman is is uh the
creator of this show
uh i think he's gonna be interested in
the legacy
of uh of like the black cap isaiah
bradley
uh and i would love to see that shield
go on to the isaiah
bradley family his uh grandson is elijah
bradley patriot
uh fans are kind of mixed on patriot of
the young avengers comics they're kind
of mixed on the young avengers comics in
general so i don't know how
uh exact they'll be with their
adaptation of the young avengers
like for example i think miss marvel
might be part of the young avengers
lineup in the mcu
i don't know if they're gonna have hulk
lean uh just because i don't think they
are
that's a lot to ask i think about
general viewers but i would love to see
it
um but i do think that uh
it's either gonna go in that direction
because it's i don't think it'll end up
in the sands of
hands of sam and bucky i think right now
sam might be feeling some imposter
imposter syndrome carrying it but maybe
he all it's okay for him just to be
falcon falcon's an awesome character i
don't need him to be
captain america and i kind of want
either
it to go to the bradley family or no one
and maybe it just stays in a museum
we see somebody carting it in a giant
wooden crate into a big stack of wooden
crates
as the raiders the lost dark music place
yeah covenant style
top men are taking care of that shield
okay i like that
i think that uh it has to be bucky and i
think
the reason it has to be bucky is it has
to complete bucky's
character arc from it brings him in a
full
360 degree circle he's the only person
from cap's era still alive he's his
friend
he was his original protector when cap's
parents were gone and he was little
steve rogers
five foot two ninety two pounds bucky
offered him shelter a place to live
he offered him protection so now
all of this has happened he's become
winner soldier he was feared dead and
then
even worse he was feared to be a
murderer as a bloodthirsty killer
and he's come all the way back to being
a hero again but how do you really come
all the way back you become
the hero of heroes captain america by
wielding the shield so i think that
in order to necessitate the full uh
three-dimensional 360-degree character i
guess we'll call it a character sphere
not an arc uh bucky's got to get his
hands on the shield for at least a
little while
i think again i'm gonna kind of um you
know dance between those two theories so
i think the show
will will end up being about um
what it takes to not only uh be captain
america but what it means to be captain
america and therefore i think
uh this will be a journey about how sam
ends up
as as the new captain america because as
we know in end game he
was a little bit torn about receiving
the shield he did have that impostor
syndrome as eric mentioned he didn't
really feel like he had earned it or
had the right to even wield it and uh
and sam
uh i mean and cap picked tap picked
sam to have the shield and he probably
talked to bucky about it too so bucky
would want to honor that
cap's decision as far as you take on the
mantle so i think the show will be about
getting it back like maybe the show will
start with you know
sam practicing with the shield against
the tree and then the u.s government
will come and
ask to have it back because you know
it's the ssr property it's us property
it's ours we own it and maybe as a good
soldier he'll
oblige and give it back and then as we
see john walker
um as the new cap and as a puppet
essentially
he'll start to maybe fail or ruin the
name of captain america and that will
really
cause the driving force between behind
sam as far as
what is his duty to his country and what
he feels right uh
within him and and finding your own
morals and your own
uh where you want to plant yourself like
a tree as sharon carter says that's what
really makes you captain america so i
think
this will be about sam finding out what
it means and and
earning that title as captain america
and
well and getting back to what tommy said
i think they will actually have bucky
wield it for a minute because
um i am also a huge fan of the bucky cap
and they're going to want to service
that in some way but maybe that'll show
us
even bucky saying yeah you know i i
can't do it right now maybe he still has
some of the hydra
you know programming in his mind and so
they'll probably have him do it and the
show will
maybe bounce around who's going to have
it who's going to have it and it'll be
about who will earn it and who deserves
it and that'll be sam
i like tom's really quick sorry i like
tom's theory
i think you guys are all wrong so
let me tell you i love that i'm like i'm
the host i say who's gonna win the show
but i'm gonna throw my theories up in
here too
i can't stop i need i wanna add my two
cents that's it's so hard to not add
your two cents to this
because i agree i agree but i also think
with uh so we are aware that the the
shield main so much
and i think sam wilson will be like i'm
not captain america
i the shield is not mine steve rogers
was an incredible guy that like
influenced me that influenced all of us
but we need to recognize that we
shouldn't
put him on this like pedestal we
shouldn't symbolize him like this
he wouldn't want this he would want us
to be our own superheroes and be our own
people
so i think sam wilson will stay falcon
and just be like here
put this in a museum if you want do like
take it
bury it underground like a dog but he's
like we shouldn't
put this in the most highest like we
shouldn't praise this and make it an all
in because i think especially with the
us agent coming in
they're recognizing that the blip
happened and the superheroes were gone
and the blip happened because the
superheroes couldn't stop it
so it's like we want a different
superhero and it's like
maybe we should just be there for
ourselves i know it's like
such a corny thing to say and also like
realistically
they i can't fight thanos i can't fight
like a demon or a god
but i think but i think with that
that shield will sam wilson's gonna be
like
no we all need to look into it further
look into ourselves recognize that we
he's a his own being and we are our own
being
yeah that is my two cents uh with that
being said
if anything if he wants to counter it
jessica i i really love that idea i
i think that's a really good point um
because i think
you know we learned that like uh captain
america did embody
more than just that shield and he
embodied a sense of selflessness and i
think that's core to this show is that
he was cap steve rogers never
comfortable in the spotlight
yeah he hated the smithsonian exhibit
like he walked around just cringing at
everything
and when he was on the uso tour he hated
it so it's kind of one of those
worthiness things if you want it you
don't deserve it
that's why i'm excited to see the us
agent come play because
i know him as like the villain not like
the villain per se not the villain per
se i should i should
clear that up and just so he's kind of
like black adam where it's like i see
where you're coming from but you're
doing it in a bad way
like you're doing in a bad manner um
he's his own paradox
so i'm excited to see that because cap
was always like the opposite
cap was like especially in like civil
war where he was like no
i shouldn't have to ask permission to go
save the day and they're like yeah but
we're
killing people by accident we recognize
that and he was like no
so i think it's gonna be great to see
like the us agent come in and be like
why like he should have signed those
papers he wasn't
he wasn't a real person that loved the
world
i love the world if anybody has any
final words because i'm about to give
out these cookies
give us cookies these cookies these
cookies are going to you guys
tommy gets three cookies yeah he knows
me too
well we've been doing too many shows
together and he knows that if you bring
up bass i'm gonna give you an extra
cookie
i'm gonna give you an extra cookie so
tommy are three also because
i truly do give bucky the lowest
like i'm like no he's not gonna be
captain america like he's not going to
be
he's a sleeper agent like it doesn't
make sense to do that
but he does deserve like a second chance
and i'm just not giving it to him so i
like your outlook on it like he does
deserve it
you two again because tom you were close
to mine
again we have the same mind i hate vox
and i just hate [ __ ] well for the record
i don't hate
both paid boss that earlier before the
show so let's try figuring this out
tom i'm also giving you three cookies
three cookies
because we have the same idea and voz
you
punk i'm giving you i'm giving
you four 40.
cookies i'm giving you four i didn't say
40 cookies i said 400
cookies you this is a monopoly you don't
know how to count so many
you are not the banker hey i love buck i
actually
really i i would love to see him wield
it for
like at least an episode just because i
i agree with jess
he needs he deserves some redemption and
some answer on whether or not he's still
you know psycho
and i would love and even that one
moment that he had the shield in cap
one and got bust off the train that was
my favorite that was great oh
god okay this is the part of the show
where i want to hear what you guys have
to say because this is another rogue
question
it's not theories it's real question
wrong question
if steve rogers does in fact die if he
dies like he's stone cold
how vase trips and falls because that's
what he assumes that how he'll die
boss said that you guys i did if he dies
during the falcon and winter soldier
series
and little flowers what will his family
request be sent
well he doesn't have a family so that's
the depressing
hey maybe he had kids with peggy take
away those cookies look take away them
cookies
right now technically if he marries if
he marry if he goes back in time or if
the
old cap is married to uh peggy the niece
is his niece
that he kiss so he does have one family
member who he was sexually attracted to
i'm gonna concur with tommy he doesn't
have a family so nothing
you guys are so dark i'm not giving you
a cookie
i'm not getting you guys in little
flowers
uh steve rogers requests you donate your
make a small donation to the american
swing band
foundation due to steve's lifelong
affinity for old-timey music
well into the 90s and 2000s that's true
that's true yeah he might ask or he just
might ask for um
if he didn't finish anything on his
little list he'd be like okay send me
some blu-rays of like star trek let me
put a little pad to everything else that
i didn't get to finish bring it over
maybe he'll do that too
yeah because i know the fans will be
upset i'm giving this cookie to tommy
i'm not happy with what you said but i'm
gonna give you that
theory last row question in the
one division making of documentary that
came out last week catherine han
described her character as a bloomin
onion
because of the layers that get peeled
back as the series goes
what delicious dish best describes you
and why
kookaroo chicken don't like that name
is that a real dish oh it's like
cucumber chicken or something
tommy i hate you okay
i like that i like that i like i like a
buffalo chicken so that's a good one
that's a good one you guys think think
take your time i think i think i got
mine i think i would be like
the outback steakhouse surf and turf
because the surf and turf
i'm a pacific islander so you got the
little surf part there you can get a
little bit of your seafood you know
but then you got the turf you got the uh
as you would say beefcake
got some prime prime uh steak right here
as some would say probably not in the
comments but on other places they would
so i probably would be
the surf and turf um because i'm also
like
decently proud not too expensive but not
the cheapest thing on their either oh
i like that i love that you guys are
doing good
boss have fun trying to come up after
these two i'm just a cold mozzarella
stick
that's a good one too damn it
you know how you know everyone saw
you'll order mozzarella sticks and just
one of them wasn't cooked all the or was
it heated
or cried all the way through so it's
just kind of cold in the middle
so you grab it and you think it's going
to be delicious just like you know you
click on one of our videos it's so
nice oh that thumbnail looks so
intriguing and then you get to it and
then you eat it you're like well it's
mostly cheese but like i feel like all
right
i don't know about this and then at the
end of the day it's not good for you
no i disagree i disagree you're the hot
fresh hot out the oven mozzarella sticks
with the dip but you know maybe you
maybe you feel like you feel like
tomorrow you'll feel like yesterday's
mozzarella sticks maybe
but today when you click on new
rockstars it's the fresh write-up served
right to your table
that's you but as soon as the episode
comes out of whatever we're talking
about it becomes yesterday's mozzarella
okay that is true yeah i the thing is
that is the funniest thing i've ever
heard any like i imagine like a
kindergarten class be like what
what food are you and a child's like i'm
the cold mozzarella
the one that's not cooked all the way
through and you thought
you were gonna bite into a decadent
melty cheese and it's
cold and frozen i love it but it's not
you
not you at all
send him packages of cold mozzarella
sticks i hate to say it
but i gotta give that point to tommy
like a buffalo it's so it's that itself
has so much sauce so much texture you're
like oh
this person's gonna be great i love the
idea of the
surf and turf that is a great that's a
great explanation
that one was amazing so tommy you have
seven points
and tom you have six points
whoa no by lied you have seven points as
well
no no you have six i'm doing my math so
you guys i'm so sorry you got six
eric how do you do this and then eric
you have four five six
seven point five you little
butthole 407.5
you don't know how to count cookies 400
cookies
you politely beat tommy by point five
cookies by literally
a half a cookie and i earned every half
a cookie
oh my god that was rogue theory
i'm leaving off a mad note because boss
should have not got that
thank you for joining us tom michelson
tommy bechtel and eric glass where do
they find you guys at online
you can find me on bumble i just bought
the deluxe package where i can reverse
if i've made a horrible mistake uh and
then you can find me at
tommybechtold on twitter you can follow
me at luluclemons
uh lulu underscore clemens louis
clements on everywhere else support our
channel by checking out one of our many
great merch options at
thenewrockstarsmerch.com
um do like subscribe comment
don't dislike on new rockstars on
youtube and a reminder to download the
stereo app by going to stereo dot com
new rockstar so you can listen to our
four weekly live
shows not one not two not three
before including inside marvel with eric
voss at mt
talking about the premiere episode of
falcon in the winter soldier
yes download the app for free on apple
and android and create an avatar that
talks when you talk for your profile
that slightly looks like you because
people love to say mine doesn't look
like me
see you next time bye
[Music]
you